اعتقل بلا تهمه وسلب حقه في الكلام فاضرب
عن الطعام مطالبا بحريته وبعد نحو ثلاثه
اشهر على الجوع في السجون الاسرائيليه
توفي الاسير الفلسطيني خضر عدنان القيادي
بحركه الجهاد الاسلامي الفلسطينيه تاركا
وراءه عائله من عشره افراد كان يمني النفس
بلقائهم من جديد رئيس وزراء السلطه
الفلسطينيه محمد شتيا تهم اسرائيل بتنفيذ
اغتيال متعمد برفضها طلب الافراج عن
الاسير وابقائه في زنزانته وعدم تقديم
الرعايه الطبيه له عدنان اعتقل نحو 12 مره
وقضى في السجون اسرائيل نحو ثمان سنوات
فيما تعيد هذه الحادثه للاذهان حوادث
وفيات سابقه في المعتقلات الاسرائيليه
فمئات الفلسطينيين سبق ان توفوا وهم رهن
الاعتقال لكن عدنان هو اول فلسطيني يتوفى
نتيجه اضرابه عن الطعام